The following content is
provided under a Creative
Commons license.
Your support will help
MIT OpenCourseWare
continue to offer high quality
educational resources for free.
To make a donation, or
view additional materials
from hundreds of MIT courses,
visit MIT OpenCourseWare
at ocw.mit.edu.
[MUSIC PLAYING]
PROFESSOR: When we introduced
the discrete Fourier transform,
one of the important aspects of
that transform that I stressed
was the fact that the
discrete Fourier transform,
as opposed to the
Fourier or z transform,
actually has implications
in terms of implementing
discrete time linear systems.
I commented, or suggested,
that in fact, a linear system,
or a digital filter could
be implemented explicitly
by computing the discrete
Fourier transform of a unit
sample response and
an input sequence,
multiplying these transforms
together, and then computing
the inverse discrete
Fourier transform.
There is a very efficient
algorithm, in fact,
for computing the discrete
Fourier transform.
And so it will turn out, and
we won't see this right away,
but we'll see it toward the
end of this set of lectures,
it will turn out
that, in fact, that's
a very efficient way, often
of implementing a convolution
or implementing
a digital filter.
Well, in the last
lecture, we saw
that computing discrete
Fourier transforms,
multiplying those together,
and then computing
the inverse discrete
Fourier transform
doesn't give us a convolution
in the usual sense.
In other words, it doesn't
give us a linear convolution,
it gives us a
circular convolution.
And one of the
important considerations
in using the discrete
Fourier transform
to implement a digital filter
or a discrete time system
is to account for
this circularity,
or to modify the circular
convolution so that it looks
like a linear convolution.
So in this lecture, what I would
like to concentrate on, in fact
entirely for the whole
lecture, is a discussion
of circular convolution,
with the hope
that at the end of
this lecture there
will be a very intuitive
feeling for what
circular convolution means.
And then also, how you can
use circular convolution
to implement a
linear convolution,
and consequently, to
implement a discrete time
linear system, for example,
to implement a digital filter.
Well, first of all, to remind
you of the convolution property
that we derived last time, we
found that multiplying discrete
Fourier transforms leads to
a circular convolution, which
we denoted with
an n and a circle
around it, meaning an N
point circular convolution.
And what that basically
corresponded to
was a periodic convolution of
two periodic sequences, which
are generated from these
finite length sequences,
by periodically repeating them
with a period of capital N.
And then finally, extracting
one N point period from that.
The result being the circular
convolution of x1 of n
with x2 of n.
Notationally, also
sometimes we wrote
this in a slightly
different way where
the periodic sequence,
x1 tilde of m or n
could also be written
with a modular notation,
a double parentheses, and
a subscript capital N,
indicating that x1 of n or m--
x1 tilde of m is
generated from x1 of m
by simply taking this
argument, modulo capital M--
capital N.
So this is an alternative
way of writing this.
And finally, I pointed
out in the last lecture,
that if we just look
at this expression,
we see that x1 tilde of m, or
equivalently x1 of m, modulo
capital N, only involves
values of this argument from 0
to capital N minus 1 and
consequently as an alternative,
we can replace here x1 of m.
So this was an expression
for circular convolution
of the two finite length
sequences x1 of n and x2 of n.
To remind you of
how the mechanics
of the circular convolution
are carried out,
I showed you last time
the circular convolution
of one finite length
sequence, x1 of m and x2 of m.
And let me re-stress a
couple of important points.
First of all, we form from x1
of m, rather from x2 two of m,
x2 of n minus m modulo
capital N. And for example,
if little n equals
0, so that we're
looking at x2 of minus
m modulo capital N,
that corresponds to
flipping this over and then
taking the values, module
capital N, which basically
corresponds to
flipping this over,
the points that
come off the end get
wrapped around back onto this
side, as I've illustrated here.
Then if we shift,
and I've indicated
with these dashed lines
what would correspond
to the periodic
extension of this,
although it's the interval
from 0 to capital N minus 1,
which is the interval
that I want to focus on.
All right.
Well, now as we change n, if
this is generally n minus m,
that corresponds to a shift
left or right of this sequence.
And if, let's say we
look at x2 of 1 minus m,
modulo capital N.
That corresponds
to shifting this sequence
to the right by one point.
And as this point
falls off the end,
it wraps around to
the other side, which
is what I've illustrated here.
And then if we shift so
that little n is equal to 2,
another point wraps
around the end,
as I've indicated, et cetera.
And that's the kind of
shifting that gets carried out.
In other words, it's a circular
shift that's implemented.
To form the convolution, then
for example, for little n
equals 1, we multiply this set
of values by this set of values
and carry out the sum.
And as I indicated
last time, it's
straightforward to see
that the answer comes out
to be unity over the interval
0 to capital N minus 1.
But the important point,
and the important picture
that I tried to
stress last time,
was the notion of
thinking of the sequences
as being wrapped around
a cylinder, x1 of n
wrapped around a
cylinder, x2 of minus n
wrapped around a cylinder, one
cylinder put inside the other,
and then as we form
the convolution,
the cylinders are turned
with respect to each other,
and the values multiplied--
successive values multiplied and
then added around the cylinder.
And that's the picture
of circular convolution.
Now there are other
ways of looking
at circular convolution.
And one of them can be
suggested by referring back
to this view graph.
We saw that we could express
the circular convolution
in this form, or
equivalently, what
this means, what this equation
means, or can be interpreted
as, is as the linear convolution
of x1 of n and x2 tilde of n,
or equivalently, x2 to
of n modulo capital N,
and then one period
extracted from that.
So in fact, another way of
looking at circular convolution
would be to form the linear
convolution of x1 of n
with the periodic
counterpart of x2 of n,
carry out that
linear convolution
and then extract one period,
which is what this function r
sub capital N of n is doing.
How can we get the periodic
sequence from x2 of n?
Well, we could do that, for
example, by convolving x2 of n
with a pulse train where
the spacing of the pulses
is capital N. And that's
illustrated on the next view
graph.
So that from the equation
that we just saw,
one possible way of thinking
of circular convolution
is as the generation of the
periodic function x2 of n.
By convolving x2 of
n with a pulse train,
then a linear convolution
of that with x1 of n,
and then finally,
extracting one period,
which is what this function,
multiplying x3 tilde of n does.
So we could generate
a pulse train
by taking a system whose
unit sample response is
1 at a spacing of capital
N, and it's 0 otherwise.
Kicking that system with the
unit sample, in which case,
we get this pulse train out.
Using that as the
excitation to a system
whose unit sample response is
x2 of n, and what we'll get then
is x2 of n convolved
with this pulse train,
or x2 of n repeated at
intervals of capital N,
but that's x2 tilde of n, that's
the periodic sequence that we
want.
That's the periodic
counterpart of x2 of n.
And so that is
what we have here.
Using that as the
input to a system
whose unit sample
response is x1 of n,
and then the output is the
periodic convolution of x1
of n with x2 of n.
We extract one period
and we get finally,
the circular convolution of the
finite length sequences x1 of n
an x2 of n.
Well, the fact that we could
view the circular convolution
in terms of a cascade
of systems of this type
leads to a very important and
interesting interpretation
of circular convolution.
In particular, let's
look at these systems,
cascaded as they are here.
So we have then, the cascade
of these three systems
to generate the circular
convolution, which is x3 of n,
the circular convolution
of x1 of n and x2 of n.
So this then is three systems
linear shift invariant systems
and cascade.
And one of the important things
that we know about linear shift
invariant systems
which are cascaded
is that the order in which
they're cascaded is irrelevant.
That's something we showed
in one of the early lectures.
So in fact, we can interchange
the order of these systems
any way that we want to.
And in particular,
let's interchange
the order of these systems
by taking this system which
generates the pulse
train, putting that
at the end of this
cascade chain so
that instead of
this cascade then,
we have x2 of n
cascaded with x1 of n,
cascaded with p
sub capital N of n.
And then of course, r sub n
to extract the single period.
Well, what does this mean?
This means that I
can equivalently
form the circular convolution
of x1 of n and x2 of n
by first forming the linear
convolution of x1 and x2.
That's of course, what the
impulse response of these two
systems and cascade is.
And then using that
as the excitation
to a system whose unit sample
response is a pulse train.
So I can think of this then
as the linear convolution.
That convolved with a pulse
train, one period extracted,
and the result is a
circular convolution.
That's a very useful and
important interpretation
of circular convolution.
And the way to sort of
say it in words, this
isn't exactly correct,
but more or less
the way to say it in words is
that the circular convolution
can be formed from a linear
convolution plus aliasing.
You see this linear
convolution in general,
is going to be
longer than capital
N. The output of this system
is this linear convolution
repeated over and over again,
added up over and over again
with a spacing of capital N.
So there is an interference,
if you want to call it that,
between the successive replicas
of this linear convolution as
they come out of this system.
That's the aliasing,
that's why aliasing
is stuck into that phrase.
But the way to summarize
it or think about it
is as circular
convolution corresponding
to linear convolution
plus aliasing.
So here it is said again,
circular convolution
equals linear convolution
plus aliasing.
What I mean by that is that if
I have the linear convolution
of x1 of n and x2 of n, which
I'm denoting by x3 hat of n,
and I want the
circular convolution,
the N point circular convolution
of x1 of n with x2 of n,
I can get the
circular convolution
from the linear convolution by
taking the linear convolution
and convolving it with a
pulse train with a spacing
of capital N, or equivalently
adding it to itself,
delayed by capital N, 2
capital N minus capital N,
minus 2 capital N, et
cetera, and then extracting
a single period.
And often when you carry out
a circular convolution of two
sequences or want to
examine properties
of circular convolution,
the notion or interpretation
of circular convolution
as linear convolution
plus aliasing is an extremely
useful sort of picture to have.
So it's the kind
of phrase that you
should repeat to yourself
two or three times for a week
before you go to bed.
And in a short time, you'll
understand the relationship
between circular convolution and
linear convolution very well.
Well, let's look at a
couple of examples of this.
Here is a sequence, x1 of n,
it's a six-point sequence.
And let's carry out the
circular convolution
of this sequence
with itself, that
makes it a relatively
straightforward example.
And let's do that
by using the notion
that circular convolution
is linear convolution
plus aliasing.
So we want first of all, to
form the linear convolution
of x1 of n and x2 of n.
And as you should recall from
similar examples in the earlier
lectures, and examples that
you've worked in the study
guide, the linear convolution
of this sequence with itself
is a triangular sequence.
We of course, take
this sequence,
flip it over, and
slide it past itself.
And as we slide along, we
accumulate more and more
points.
And so, the linear convolution
of x1 of n with x2 of n
is a triangular sequence,
as I've indicated here.
Well, now to form the
circular convolution of x of n
and x2 of n.
What we need to do is repeat
this triangular sequence over
and over again, add it to itself
with a delay of capital N.
And capital N in this case is 6.
So we want this sequence
repeated over and over again
and added to itself with a
spacing of six and then 12
and then 18, et cetera.
Or equivalently, we want the
linear convolution convolved
with a pulse train where
the spacing of the pulses
is capital N, which
in this case is 6.
So I've indicated here, the
envelope of the triangular
sequence, that's
the envelope here,
the envelope of the
triangular sequence.
And you can see that if
we overlap these triangles
by a spacing of
six, then in fact,
these points will get
added to these points.
Or when we add up the triangles,
they'll always add up to 1.
So when we carry out
this convolution,
what we end up with are
values that are constant
from minus infinity
to plus infinity,
that's due to the
convolution with this term.
Finally, to form the
N point, or six-point
in this case, circular
convolution, what
we want to extract
are the six points
of this sequence one,
two, three, four, five,
six, those six points,
set the rest to 0,
and the result is, as
I've indicated here.
So this then is the N
point circular convolution
of x1 of n with x2 of n.
This is the linear convolution
It should be clear that,
or relatively clear
that this is, in fact, the way
the circular convolution comes
out, because if you imagine
flipping this and sliding
it, modulo capital N,
or equivalently taking
this sequence and wrapping
it around the cylinder,
no matter how you twist
the cylinder you always
see the same points.
So in fact, by evaluating
the circular convolution
using modulus arguments,
you would of course,
come up with the same
result. But we see here,
how it comes out of this
notion of linear convolution
plus aliasing.
All right, well let's
look at another example.
Actually, it's the same example,
but with one slight change
to it.
Here again, I have the example
of x1 of n equal to x2 of n.
And again, we take both of
them as a boxcar sequence.
In other words, rectangular or
constant value in the interval
0 to n minus 1, and 0
outside that interval.
Again of course, then we
have the linear convolution
of these two as
a triangle, which
is what I've denoted here.
And now let's look, not at the
N point circular convolution,
but at the 2n point
circular convolution
of x1 of with x2 of n.
In that case, we want this
triangular sequence repeated
and added to itself, not
with a spacing of capital N
as in the previous example,
but with a spacing of 2 capital
N because we're doing
a 2 capital N point
circular convolution.
Well if we do that, then we
end up with this triangular
sequence added to itself
starting here, finishing over
there.
Or in general, if we convolve
it with this pulse train,
then the resulting periodic
sequence that we end up with
has triangular periods
to it with a period now,
not have capital N as we
had in the previous example,
but of 2 capital N.
Finally, to get the circular
convolution, we see that,
or we recall that we want to
extract one period of this.
So we extract a period from
0 to 2 capital N minus 1.
So we have 0 to 2
capital N minus 1.
And this result then is the 2
N point circular convolution
of x1 of n with x2 two of n.
It's interesting to
note that in this case,
the circular
convolution in fact,
came out looking like the
linear convolution of x
of n and x2 of n.
And the reason for
that we see, is
that when we did the convolution
with this pulse train,
we chose the spacing
of the pulse train
large enough so that
there was no interference
from successive replicas
of this linear convolution.
Well, that suggests
an interesting thing.
It suggests that
we could in fact,
implement a linear convolution
from a circular convolution
if we're careful enough
to pick the length
of the circular
convolution long enough.
Now what does long enough mean?
Well, long enough
means that the length
of the circular convolution
has to be longer
than the length of the
linear convolution.
You can show
incidentally, and you'll
see this in more
detail in the text,
that if you have sequence
of length capital N
and another sequence
of length capital M,
then the linear
convolution of the two
is always going to be
shorter than or equal to n
plus m minus one points.
So if we do the
circular convolution
on the basis of n plus
m minus 1, or n plus m--
well, take n plus m,
that will certainly work,
then the circular convolution
will end up corresponding
to a linear convolution.
And this is the way that we can
carry out a linear convolution
using circular convolution.
This is commonly referred
to as padding with zeros.
And what that means is treating
this N point sequence not as
an N point sequence
when we compute
the DFT, but as a sequence
of length 2 capital N,
so that if we computed
a 2 capital N point
DFT of this sequence, padding
out with capital N zeroes,
multiplied that DFT
together with itself
and then computed the inverse
DFT, what we would get,
in fact, because of the fact
that we padded out with zeroes
is a 2 N point
circular convolution,
which would correspond to
the linear convolution.
So this is the way,
then that we can
modify a circular convolution
so that it implements
for us a linear convolution.
And when we actually
implement a digital filter,
or a discrete time system
using an explicit computation
of the discrete Fourier
transform, then of course,
this is what we have to do to
avoid the circular convolution
since what we want in that
case is a linear convolution.
Well, it's important,
very important
to keep straight first
of all, the properties
of circular convolution.
Sometimes in fact,
circular convolution
is what you would like to get.
The notion, the relationship
between circular and linear
convolution, mainly this
notion of circular convolution
being equal to linear
convolution plus aliasing.
And then finally
the way in which
you can use a circular
convolution to actually
implement a linear convolution.
Now what I'd like
to do is really
cement this by illustrating
these notions, finally,
with a film which will
depict a number of things.
It's actually the
continuation of a film
that you saw in
the first lecture
that we had on discrete
time convolution.
We'll show first of
all, linear convolution
just exactly as you
had seen before.
Second of all, periodic
or circular convolution
and the difference between them.
The third thing that
the film will illustrate
is the relationship
between linear convolution
and periodic or circular
convolution, namely,
the notion of
circular convolution
as linear convolution
plus aliasing.
And finally, the fourth
thing that it will illustrate
is this notion of
padding with zeros
so that a circular
convolution can
be used to implement
a linear convolution.
So let's go to the
film now and go
through these various
examples with the hope
that at the end of this, the
notion and relationships will
really be very, vivid.
OK the convolutions sum
then, we have is the sum
of x of k, h of n minus k.
And so what we would
like to illustrate
is the operation of
evaluating this sum.
On the top we have x of k,
on the bottom we have h of k,
h of k being an exponential.
And now we see h of minus k,
namely h of k flipped over.
As we shift h of k to the
left, corresponding to n
equals minus 1, then back
to 0, and now to the right.
So we have h of 1 minus k.
And then to form y of
n, we want the product
of h of minus k
shifted with x of k,
that product summed from minus
infinity to plus infinity.
" here we see x of k times
h of 1 minus k, 2 minus k,
3 minus k, et cetera, those
multiplied and then summed from
minus infinity to plus infinity.
We see during this portion
that more and more values of h
are engaged with
non-zero values of x.
And so y of n grows until we
reach the point where values
fall off the end of the non-zero
values of x, where y of n
decays.
So this then is an illustration
of the linear convolution
of x of k with h of k.
Now what we'd like
to compare this with
is periodic convolution where
the sum is of a similar form,
but the arguments are
taken modulo capital M.
And in this case
then, the shifting
is a circular shifting rather
than a linear shifting.
On the top again, we
have x of k, modulo M.
On the bottom, h of k, modulo m.
Now h minus k, modulo m,
and we see that as we shift,
the shift is circular
modulo capital M.
So there's 0, h of 0 minus
k, modulo capital M, h of 1
minus k, modulo capital
M that was shifted
to the right circularly by 1.
And now we want to look at
the sum from 0 to m minus 1
of the product of those.
And the thing to notice
is that since x of k
is of length capital
M, as we implement
the circular shift of h of
minus k, the values of h of k,
or h if minus k are always
engaged with unity values of x,
and consequently, y always comes
out to have the same value.
To see the relationship between
the periodic and aperiodic
convolution, namely the
aliasing relationship,
we can simply look at the
aperiodic convolution,
or linear convolution,
take the second m values,
added to the first
m values, and when
we carry out that sum,
what we get is a constant.
In general, the relationship is
that the circular convolution
is y of n plus y of n
plus capital M, y of n
plus 2 capital M, et cetera.
Next, what we would
like to illustrate
is the fact that the
linear convolution
can be obtained from
a circular convolution
if we pad out with zeros.
So now we're going to implement
the circular convolution,
but notice that
we've padded x of k
out with a number of zeros.
In that case, as we do the
circular shifting of h,
the values on the right
are multiplied only
by the zero values that
we appended x with,
and so this looks exactly the
same as if we were sliding h
in from the left-hand end.
And so what results then
is the linear convolution.
Although we're implementing a
circular convolution, because
of the fact that we've
augmented with zeros,
the resulting answer
is exactly the same
as the linear convolution
of x of n with h of n.
All right, well hopefully,
through the film
you got to see the
dynamics of convolution
in these relationships that I've
been trying so hard to stress.
And now if we return
to the example
that we were talking
about before the film,
it should be clear that
through this notion of padding
with zeros, we can implement
a linear convolution,
and thereby implement
a discrete time
linear shift invariant system
using circular convolution,
or equivalently, computing
DFTs, multiplying and computing
the inverse DFT.
Well there's only
one hitch to that,
and that's the
following, suppose
that what I wanted to implement
was a discrete time system.
Let's take the impulse response
as this sequence x1 of n.
And let's say that the
input to the filter
was also a sequence of length
capital N, or capital M.
Then, on the basis
of everything we've
been saying in this
lecture, clearly we
could do the convolution by
padding out with enough zeros,
computing the discrete
Fourier transform,
multiplying and
inverse transforming.
However, in order to
do that, obviously
for the input, before we compute
the discrete Fourier transform,
we have to wait until the
entire input comes in.
In other words, we need a
buffer that's long enough
to hold the entire input.
Furthermore what we need to do
is compute a Fourier transform,
discrete Fourier transform,
that is at least as long
as the input data.
In fact, as long
as the input data,
plus the length of the
unit sample response.
Now obviously, if we want to
filter some signal like, let's
say, one of
Beethoven's symphonies,
clearly we're not
first of all, going
to want to buffer the
entire input signal.
Second of all, you can imagine
computationally that at,
say a 10 kilohertz or 20
kilohertz sampling rate,
we'd be talking about a discrete
Fourier transform that's
astronomical in length.
So if we want to implement
a digital filter,
or a discrete time system
using this kind of approach,
then we would like to
have some strategy that
avoids the problem of having
to buffer the entire input.
And one way of doing that is
by sectioning the input signal.
So that, suppose we had as
an example, a unit sample
response which was
of length capital M,
so it runs from 0 to
capital M minus 1.
We have an input signal that's
arbitrarily long, starts at 0,
let's say, and runs on
for an indefinite length.
We can imagine sectioning
the input, sectioning x of n
into sections of some length,
and let's call the length
capital L, so that we
have a number of sections
of length capital L.
Now we know, and
you should recall
from when we
discussed convolution,
that the convolution of a
sum, the convolution of h
of n with the sum of
things is equal to the sum
of the convolutions.
So that if we generated a
set of sequences, each one
corresponding to a different
section of the input,
we could convolve each
of those with h of n,
and then add the resulting
convolutions together
to form the output y of n.
So if we section
the input, x of n,
we can then form a set of
sequences, each one of which
corresponds to one
of these sections
and is 0 outside the
interval that I've
indicated for each one of
these colored sections.
And we would end up with
a set of sub sequences
which would, for example,
look like this, x 0 of n,
corresponding to the first
l points, and 0 afterwards.
X1 of n corresponding
to the second l points,
and 0 afterwards and before.
X two of n, the next
set of l points.
X3 of n, the next
And we could continue
on like that.
Implement the convolution of
each one of these sections
with the unit sample response.
And then add the resulting
outputs together.
In that case, the
length transform
that we would need to compute
the linear convolution
of this l point section
with the input h of n,
would be where h of
n was of length m,
would be a DFT of
length l plus m minus 1.
L plus m certainly
works, but it turns out
l plus m minus 1 is enough.
Now obviously we have to
make sure that we line up.
If we have the input sections
delayed by a certain amount,
we have to make sure that we
line up the output sections.
And what we end up with then is
a set of output sub sequences
which correspond
to the convolution
of each one of the input
sections with h of n.
Now we started out with sections
of length L. We convolved those
with a unit sample
response of length m.
The resulting length
of the convolution
will be L plus m minus 1.
We've seen that in
a variety of ways.
And consequently, when we
consider adding up the outputs
from the convolution with
each one of the subsections,
if this is the point
that corresponds
to l, this is just
exactly the right delay,
we notice that
there's a tail out
of the convolution
in this section
that overlaps into
the first m minus 1,
or N points of it's
m minus 1 points,
actually, of this section.
Likewise, there are
m minus 1 points
at the tail of this one that
overlap into the first m points
here.
So that when we add up
the output sub sequences,
what we have is an
overlap between the tail
of this section and the
beginning of this one,
since this starts at l and
this runs longer than l.
Similarly, an overlap
from the tail of this
into the beginning of this one.
And that continues on.
Because of that, this technique
for suctioning and then
adding the results
together is often
referred to as the
overlap add method
because we overlap the outputs
and then add these together.
These pieces will add.
These blue pieces will add,
et cetera, down the line.
There's also another
method for sectioning
using circular convolution and
fitting the outputs together,
which is a method that is
referred to as the overlap
save method.
And that method is discussed
in some detail in the text,
and corresponds
basically, to implementing
a circular convolution
of the sections
rather than a linear
convolution as we did here.
The linear convolution, we could
get from a circular convolution
by padding with zeros.
Alternatively, we can take
the circular convolution
and discard the points
that don't correspond
to a linear convolution.
Well, there are a variety
of techniques of this type.
The important point though,
is that circular convolution
can, in fact, be used to
implement linear convolution.
It can be used to
implement digital filters
or discrete time linear systems.
And in fact, although this--
there's nothing that we've
said that clearly makes this
obvious, in fact, there
are very efficient ways
of computing the discrete
Fourier transform,
which in fact make this
notion of computing
the transform, multiplying
and inverse transforming,
an efficient method for
implementing a digital filter.
All right, well this
concludes our discussion
of the discrete
Fourier transform.
Toward the end of
this set of lectures,
we'll return actually,
to the discrete Fourier
transform again, where
at that time, what we'll
want to talk about
is specifically
the computation of the discrete
Fourier transform, which
leads to notions such as
the fast Fourier transform
algorithm.
It's that computational
efficiency
that makes some of
these ideas that we've
talked about in the last
few lectures so important
in terms of implementing
digital filters.
Thank you.
[MUSIC PLAYING]